hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's been two months since we last
updated our story so far for what
night's battle royale I believe by the
end of season X we will have a complete
story but until that day arrives here's
all the live events that make up the
fortnight's narrative so grab some
popcorn get your backside comfy use code
add Amaro in the fort night shop and
let's relive the last two years of our
gaming life the first live event which
shook the in-game world started off as a
shooting star across the skies during
season three but as the days turned into
weeks that burning fireball in the sky
looked like more than a passing comet
lookout points and viewing platforms
were constructed around the island
welcoming the meteor we all tried and
failed to predict the day it would hit
us and some even predicted alien life to
be unbarred that UFO suddenly without
warning pieces of the comet began to hit
the island destroying man-made
structures influencing fights and
causing havoc everywhere
with the introduction of season four
fortnight's island was finally hit by
more than debris large portions of the
former UFO destroyed many areas of the
map with the main impact destroying
dusty depot and turning it into a barren
hole in the ground instantaneously the
government erected barriers around the
impact site hiding away the central part
of the meteor something suspicious was
happening those remains glowed red
potentially indicating life inside
elsewhere around the islands the cleanup
began with government officials
transporting the fragments of the comet
some of which grunted anti-gravity
abilities momentarily to anyone who
touched them tilted towers narrowly
avoided complete annihilation but one
building wasn't so lucky that building
and all the other areas were renovated
over the following weeks and months
finally it looked like all the fragments
and hot rocks were being transported to
a mountain over by snobby shores the
mountain was revealed to be a lair cut
into the rock face hidden from the
majority of the island some say it was
created for a movie shoot others
believed this was a facade and a secret
government facility is housed inside
especially as a rocket was seen either
way everything was about to change after
the final meteor fragment over by the
crater was discovered opened and whoever
was inside left a trail of destruction
all the way to the mountain lair the
visitor was revealed but nothing is
known about his origins he quickly found
a way to power the rocket and then came
the day he chose to launch broadcasting
the signal to all the televisions in the
vicinity either warning the innocent of
preparing them for annihilation was he
here to conquer us or was he simply
trying to get back home what happened
next
only happened a single time and could
not be repeated here's how it went down
[Music]
the visitor somehow managed to create
ruptures in time and rifts between
dimensions although it looked like
tilted towers was about to be destroyed
a malfunction caused the rocket to warp
around the map the rift left behind
began to eat away at the four night
world with nom noms the tomato head and
the derp burger being ripped from this
reality and vanishing overnight but then
something even stranger happened items
from other worlds began to drop through
the rifts in time a stagecoach was found
above moisty mire and a huge anchor was
spotted between snobby shores and greasy
Grove which look ancient in design
perhaps Roman perhaps nas something was
definitely happening here season 5
arrived and changed the world further
once the rifts in time and space opened
the drift character was dragged onto the
island alongside the fabled der burger
midway through season five the crack in
the sky began to burn down a group of
cactuses cacti cactus cacti whichever is
correct once all the cacti were
demolished the rift did this
a mysterious cube was created which
gifted shield when close enough but
would repel any damage at the closest
player to the cube so what did we all do
we all killed each other for a while
which was fun
eventually the cube began to roll around
the map and left Nordic runes in the
ground linking back to the norstein we
found in the battle paths and the theory
of Ragnarok bringing the end to the
current world over the next month the
cube went about its business including
smashing down the building and tilted
towers which has been under construction
since season four began epic just love
to trollers back to the loading screens
saw the arrival of the enforcers which
look like intergalactic police we'll
have to wait to see what happens here
because even on the last day of season 5
nothing has been confirmed watch this
space so the cube finally made it over
to loot Lake and this happened
[Music]
the cube melted into loot lake causing
the top layer to become a repellant kind
of trampoline gel loot lake became
Thanos Lake or at least that's what the
community called it one week later
things changed yet again season six
began and the cube was not finished with
us yet
lifting the loot lake island into the
air
[Music]
the moment the floating island was
created the cube took it for a ride and
revisited all the rune spots on the
island ripping them out of the ground
and transferring some source of energy
to them before moving on to the next
over two weeks the cube island moved
around the map slowly expanding itself
through the house above once the cube
reached the final room another
phenomenon happened all the surrounding
rooms were ripped from the ground and
pulled towards the cube this time the
cube was feeding from all the rooms and
over the next few days the cube reached
its full capacity
the floating rooms dropped from the sky
and hit the ground and the cube island
went back to its home above loot lake
with its newfound energy the cube
projected a beam of light into the air
and fought nightmares began
the island became infested with the
undead these husks were everywhere the
loot lake island was smashed into pieces
but with his job done the cube began to
drain away the energy and power it had
built up for the season opened a gateway
to a zombie Cataclysm for five days we
battled against the husks the nightmare
was almost over and to mark the end
another live event brought chapter one
to a close the end of the cube rest in
peace Kevin here's how it went down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
once kept in the cube left us replacing
loot Lake with leaky Lake we thought
this must be the end but as the rainbow
dulled the cold winter air kicked in and
the next episode in the saga began
down by flush factory a mysterious
parachute was discovered with the
questionable logo which could link to
the satellite surveillance found in
save-the-world that this wasn't our
major concern because out in the
distance was a cloud of snow quickly
moving towards the island winter is
coming
suddenly aim was uncovered wearing the
exact same logo and subtly hiding in the
background of our games watching us
waiting and reporting back to someone or
something as season 7 began a huge
change to the island was witnessed the
cloud of snow hit an iceberg which hit
the island changing the entire lower
left third filling it with snow and icy
weather life went on with the destroyed
building in tilted towers once again
resurrected but for how long this time
the iceberg brought explorers to the
island who set up outposts across the
isle finally telling us who sent aim in
season 6 but this was only the beginning
as the iceberg slowly melted away
revealing a medieval castle underneath
for weeks we watched it thaw uncovering
a throne room and a dungeon below with
death traps tools of torture and sacred
dragon eggs something was going to
happen here a sword of immeasurable
power showed as the icebergs mysterious
potential and turned brother against
brother until it was once again locked
away under ice we had a taste of godlike
power for a while the island was
peaceful again we collectively stopped
and saw in the new year together but far
more was yet to come TV screens around
the island sprung into life again
warning of negative temperatures and
then it happened
above the castle a sphere as depicted in
the Explorers emblem appeared inside the
ice ball was the Ice King waking from
his slumber gaining strength and
summoning mythical energy and does that
look a little bit like Kevin just a
little bit the televisions once again
counted down the moments until the next
live event began the Ice King awake
[Music]
deep under the frozen castle something
was happening a captive was slowly
Thorin out of his icy prison his skin
was like volcanic rock over the next few
weeks the prisoner began to evolve first
removing his shackles before gaining
volcanic powers by the end of season
seven
he had become a molten God to rival the
Ice King setting up home in wailing
woods smoke and ash began to rise
suddenly something happened to change
the very shape of the Battle Royale
Island a volcano sprang up indicating
the start of season 8 the changing
landscape also attracted nearby pirates
who set up their home in lazy lagoon
this led to a three-way battle for
supremacy ice versus fire versus those
pesky pirates - as season they continued
the men in black those secret government
officials began to look for something
under the island surface dig site sprang
up overnight and finally they found it
it was there under loot Lake the place
where Kevin walked to all those seasons
ago had a secret beneath a vault
futuristic in design as time went on the
inhabitants completed tasks to open the
vault and finally the day came the vault
opened and here's what happened
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow a lot stake in there first the
community voted to bring back the drum
gun back in the present day both retail
row and tilted towers were destroyed and
remember that building which was
constantly destroyed well that was the
one and only building to live through
the volcano events well played indeed
epic games during the event Jonesy and a
human-sized banana yes that's a real
thing in fortnight Battle Royale
made their way to a hidden bunker to
provide cover whilst the volcano blasts
continued they became trapped inside for
so long that Jonesy ate his fruity Chum
until the future arrived
[Music]
set free in a new world rebuilt after
the volcano event a new tilted towers
rose up neo tilted and retail row was
replaced with a mega more the helm from
the vault can now be seen in neo tilted
but one more thing happened to confuse
us further one of the volcano blasts
cracked the ice cap at polar peak in the
ice another being can be seen a
potentially huge being is this the
all-seeing eye or is this some sort of
Godzilla size behemoth behind that sheet
of ice what will happen next we didn't
have to wait long to find out
suddenly the eye was no more polar peak
was decimated and giant footprints led
over to the sea the monster was now
circling the island waiting to strike
but what was it trying to find what was
it after his first attack at loot lake
was unsuccessful but the inhabitants of
the island knew they were lucky led by
singularity they began to build defenses
just in case that monster ever returned
over the next month a gigantic mech was
built in the form of volcano combining
five of the island's most powerful
figures the mecha teddy was complete and
moments later the Beast came back and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
however thick was that the monster knew
all about the power car in loot Lake and
try to obtain it and even though we
survived the Nexus the zero point the
orb of power was exposed cracking until
the day broke and brought with it season
X
what the hell is happening we have time
traveled but we are still in present-day
the island has been frozen moment from
the disaster that started season four
dusty is back but for how long
once again the visitor looks to be
pivotal to this story he's back again
his capsule is once again open but this
time there is no rocket at the villains
lair so the visitor needs a new plan
setting up a makeshift home over in
dusty the visitor began to build rift
beacons designed to harness the power of
the cracked op each week he used these
machines to change the island going back
in time hundreds of years or just a few
months what was he up to his third
attempt ended in complete failure he
vaporized the entire rec center and
caused cracks in between dimensions
where the hell is this leading can you
predict the next story beat in this saga
and there we go we are up to date
remember to check in on me every week as
we do map updates to piece together the
next part of the story and that's also
where I shout out the people who are
kind enough to use code atom arrow in
the font I shop those people make my
fortnight videos possible and they
really appreciate it I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade I hope you've
enjoyed this and I'll see you next time
[Music]